well russia threatening stance against
ukraine is sparking concerns that moscow
may also be willing to use force
elsewhere sweden has sent troops to its
baltic sea island of gotland following
an increase in russian naval activity in
nearby waters the island is
strategically located off the coast of
the russian exclave of kaliningrad some
analysts have likened it to an aircraft
carrier in the middle of the baltic sea
sweden's not a member of nato and
therefore not covered by the alliance's
defense clause
dw correspondent terry schultz has been
speaking with swedish defense minister
peter huldqvist
president biden says he believes that
president putin now
is likely to invade ukraine what's the
view from sweden do you think the same
you have one hundred thousand soldiers
around ukraine you have a
milled full military access for the
russians to in belarus and
we have also have a history around
hybrid attacks around l2 towards
lithuania and poland and we have a very
brutal language also from from kremlin
so
that has a real impact also on the total
security situation including sweden and
what's happened if they attack
ukraine
we cannot know but we say like this that
we cannot exclude an armed attack
against sweden and what we want to do
just now is to be very clear that we are
ready to defend sweden and because of
that we also are doing what we are doing
on the island of gutland and what do you
think the likelihood is not that he will
invade ukraine but that he will come as
far as sweden that he would dare to try
to see scotland
i do not speculate about these sort of
things but
experience
during the years and if you look at
different sort of military activities is
that you never know if something starts
also other things can happens so we must
be prepared for also scenarios that we
do not want to think about
and because of that we think it's very
important to be clear that sweden is
ready to defend its serenity and
integrity and do it
both by ourselves but also together with
other countries that we have cooperated
with for many many years but that in
fact raises the question of nato
membership for sweden which is something
that is discussed uh
in various um stages uh over the years
but now is is again at a high point you
yourself your party the social democrats
are against joining nato has this
changed your calculation at all no we
have built it step by step up or
own military capability as a nation and
at the same time we have around 20
defense cooperation agreements with
other countries we have also very deep
relationship with finland with
with military planning beyond peace
together with them and we have also
coordinated planning with some other
countries so we have prepared for a
situation when we need interoperability
and the possibility to work with other
countries and if something happened here
in our region
all of the countries here will be
will have a direct impact from that and
nato will also have a direct impact from
that so we have to deal with the
situation together
swedish defense minister peter hulkfist
talking to dw correspondent terry
schultz